I'm your caddie today.
Asking around, everyone
It seems to be you're the unanimous best golfer here.
I grew up playing. took lessons.
I played competitively in high school
a little bit, a couple tournaments.
So, yeah, It’s something
I like to do in the offseason.
You got some wind here?
We’re good. That’s my job.
alright. Pitching wedge works.
Yeah, a little choked down on her maybe?
Yeah, I’ll do that.
Oh, baby.
if we get a hole in one first guy...
Oh, my God.
Well, it's just good caddying.
Seven feet, seven inches.
That's going to be tough to beat.
I think.
this guy's a stick.
Sit down.
Get in, Get in.
Oh, no.
We needed the backspin there.
That's probably my fault.
I should have gave you a smaller club.
Oh, yeah.
Come right a little.
That looks really nice.
Okay.
On the green. That's great. Yeah.
That's automatic birdie.
With your hands...
What would be your celebrity foursome?
If you could choose anyone to play with,
who would it be?
If you don't say the one guy I'm thinking of,
we might fight.
Okay, so the first guy I'd go with,
Mark Wahlberg, number one.
Number two, I mean, you got to throw
Tiger Woods in there.
Big Tiger fan.
And then you, man.
I’ll caddy, I’ll caddy.
Okay. So you don't count as -
No, I don't Count.
Throw Margot Robbie in there.
Oh, nice. I love that.
I thought @Tb12
was going to get a shout out.
Tom Brady.
Sorry, Margot.
She can still Come.
That might be excellent.
Come on, get.
Huh?
Oh, that was really nice, too.
That was nice.
All right. Hey, proud of you for that.
Thanks, buddy.
Well, it looks nice.
Get up.
We might have to go to the -
This is bad caddying.
I should have known.
yeah, You should've known after the drives.
Oh, my God.
Should we try driver?
Should i try?
Let's go Driver.
Oh, my God.
Go.
All right, You're -
You're dancing.
That's okay.
That's old man Golf right there.
Actually, it might come out of my hands.
That’d be so good.
That might be all right, though
get down.
Get down!
Oh, boy.
I told you it was going to happen.
I mean, the men called his shot.
We.
We might need some baby powder in here.
could be great.
oh, backspin?
Little check?
oh, oh.
I play better golf in here.
This is just an absolute clinic.
Get down on it.
What a read by me.
Good job.
Yeah, Good shot. Six feet.
What was Kels?
That's #1 right?
This is.
Do you have any hole in ones? You must.
I have one on a par four
on a bachelor party.
Oh, my God.
Where was it?
Arizona.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
That must have been a night.
All time favorite golf movie?
The Greatest Game.
Shia LaBeouf.
that's a beast mode of a movie.
Is it?
That's a good movie.
come down
eight feet, nine inches.
You're in third place.
Third.
If you could describe
your swing as an emoji,
what would that emoji be?
Hmm?
Banana.
Slice.
Yeah.
I like thaT.
banana.
Banana?
Yeah
that's good.
JONNY!
Go.
The leader.
Oh, the leader.
Yeah. You’RE good.
I think for you, kind of just go
a little right of that
rock on the left.
ALRIGHT, LET IT FADE IN THERE?
Butter it in.
And we've seen those before.
I mean, what a play by me, NO?
THAT’S A good caddy.
Oh. Oh, my God.
THAT WOULD have been so good.
We split this.
If you could describe your swing
as an emoji, what would you use
as an emoji?
Hmm.
Maybe, like, the.
Like, butter emoji.
Yeah.
THAT is butter.
That could be a BEAUT.
sit.
Oh
this guy's a golfer.
Short toO?
big bounce.
Oh!
It's not going to do it
But I’LL TAKE that.
you beat your brother by...
one foot, which is nice.
Really?
Yeah.